Je voudrais commencer par une anecdote, à la Seth Godin,
qui m'est arrivée quand j’avais 12 ans.
Mon oncle Ed m’avait donné un magnifique pull bleu --
du moins je pensais qu’il était beau.
Et il avait ces rayures floquées sur le ventre,
et le Mont Kilimandjaro et le Mont Méru étaient comme
en travers du torse, ça aussi c’était floqué.
Et je le portais à chaque fois que je le pouvais,
pensant que c’était la chose la plus fabuleuse que je possédais.
Jusqu’à ce jour en classe de 3ème,
où j’étais là debout avec des garçons de l’équipe de foot.
Et mon corps avait visiblement changé, et Matt Mussolina,
qui était sans aucun doute ma bête noire au lycée,
a dit bien fort
que nous n’avions plus besoin d’aller très loin pour faire du ski,
mais qu’on pouvait tous aller skier désormais sur les Monts Novogratz.
(Rires)
Et j’étais me suis sentie si humiliée et mortifiée
que j’ai couru immédiatement chez moi voir ma mère et l’ai maudite
de m’avoir laissé un jour porter ce pull hideux.
On est allé en voiture jusqu’à une œuvre de charité, et nous avons jeté ce pull
non sans cérémonie,
et j'avais en tête que je n'aurais jamais plus à penser à ce pull
ni à le revoir de ma vie.
Passons rapidement -- 11 ans plus tard, j’ai 25 ans.
Je travaille à Kigali, Rwanda, je fais mon footing dans les pentes raides,
quand je vois, à 3 mètres en face de moi, un petit garçon -- 11 ans --
courant vers moi, portant mon pull.
Et là je pense, non, c’est pas possible.
Mais bon, curieuse, je courre pour le rattraper -- bien sûr
ça l’a effrayé comme pas Dieu possible --
je l'attrappe par le col, je le retourne, et c’est mon nom
qui est écrit dans le col de ce pull.
Je raconte cette histoire, parce qu’elle m’a servi et me sert encore
comme une métaphore sur le niveau d’interconnexion
que nous avons tous sur cette planète.
Si souvent nous ne réalisons pas à quel point notre action ou notre inaction
affecte des gens que nous pensons ne jamais rencontrer ou connaître.
Je raconte aussi cette histoire parce qu’elle exprime un contexte plus large
de ce que l’aide humanitaire est et peut être.
Que d’une œuvre de charité en Virginie, ce pull
soit passé dans cette organisation plus importante,
qui à ce moment-là donnait des millions de vêtements d'occasion en Afrique et en Asie.
Ce qui était une très bonne chose, et fournissait des vêtements à très bas coût.
Et en même temps, certainement au Rwanda,
cela détruisait le commerce local.
Non pas pour dire que cela n’aurait pas du,
mais que nous devons répondre mieux aux questions
sur lesquelles on doit réfléchir quand on pense aux conséquences
de nos actes.
Donc, je vais me concentrer sur le Rwanda, dans les années 1985, 1986,
où je faisais 2 choses.
J’avais démarré une boulangerie avec 20 mères célibataires.
Nous étions appelées les Bad News Bears, et notre idée était que
nous allions nous accaparer le marché de la vente d’en-cas à Kigali,
ce qui n’était pas dur parce qu’il n’y en avait pas avant nous.
Et parce que nous avions un bon modèle de développement, c’est ce que nous avons fait,
et j’ai vu ces femmes instiguer le changement à petite échelle.
Mais au même moment, j’ai démarré une banque de micro-finance,
et demain Iqbal Quadir va parler de la Grameen,
qui est la grand-mère de toutes les banques de micro-finance,
qui est désormais un mouvement mondial -- on appelle ça un développement mimétique --
mais à l’époque c’était assez nouveau, particulièrement dans une économie
qui passait du troc au commerce.
on avait juste sur de nombreux points.
On s’est concentré sur un modèle de développement, on a insisté sur l’implication personnelle.
Mes femmes prenaient leurs propres décisions au bout du compte
sur comment elles allaient utiliser cet accès au crédit
pour monter leur propre petite entreprise, avoir plus de revenus
pour pouvoir mieux prendre soin de leur famille.
Ce que nous n’avions pas compris, c’est ce qui se passait tout autour de nous,
aux confluents de la peur, des tensions ethniques
et certainement de ce jeu de l’aide humanitaire qui se jouait
de manière invisible mais néanmoins palpable au Rwanda,
qui à cette époque, recevait 30 % de son budget en aide étrangère.
Le génocide a eu lieu en 1994,
7 ans après que toutes ces femmes aient travaillé ensemble
pour bâtir ce rêve.
Et la bonne nouvelle c’est que cette institution,
cette banque, a tenu le coup.
En fait, c’est devenu le plus grand prêteur lors de la reconstruction du pays.
La boulangerie a complètement disparue,
mais ce que j’en retiens c’est l'importance de la responsabilité --
construire des choses avec des gens sur le terrain,
utiliser des modèles d’entreprises où, comme dirait Steven Levitt,
la motivation ça compte.
Comprenez moi, aussi complexe soit-elle, l’incitation compte.
Donc quand Chris m’a fait part de tout ce qui se passait
de formidable dans le monde,
qu’on voyait un changement dans l'air du temps,
d’une certaine façon je suis tout à fait d’accord avec lui,
et j’en frissonnais de voir ce qui se passait avec le G8 --
que le monde, grâce à des gens comme Tony Blair et Bono
et Bob Geldof -- le monde parle de la pauvreté dans le monde,
le monde parle de l’Afrique
d’une façon que je n’avais jamais vue de ma vie.
C’est palpitant.
Et en même temps, ce qui me tient éveillée la nuit
c'est cette peur que nous regardions les victoires du G8 --
50 milliards de dollars supplémentaires d’aide à l’Afrique,
40 milliards de dollars de réduction de dette -- comme LA victoire,
comme plus qu’une première étape, comme notre l’achat d’une bonne conscience.
Et en fait, ce que nous devons faire c’est voir tout ceci comme une première étape,
la célébrer, la clore, et reconnaître qu’il nous faut une deuxième étape
où il s’agit de faire les choses -- il s’agit du savoir-faire.
Et si vous devez retenir une chose de ce dont je parle aujourd’hui,
c’est que la seule façon de mettre fin à la pauvreté, de tourner la page de la pauvreté définitivement,
est de construire des systèmes viables sur le terrain
qui fournissent des biens et services indispensables et abordables aux pauvres,
avec des méthodes qui sont financièrement durables et utilisables à grande échelle.
Si nous faisons ça, nous pouvons vraiment faire de la pauvreté une histoire ancienne.
Et c’est ce qui -- toute cette philosophie --
m’a encouragé à créer ma tentative actuelle
appelée le Fond Acumen,
qui essaie de bâtir des mini-projets
de comment nous pourrions faire ça dans les domaines de l’eau, de la santé et du logement
au Pakistan, en Inde, au Kenya, en Tanzanie et en Egypte.
Et je veux vous parler un peu de tout ça, et de quelques exemples
pour que vous puissiez voir ce que nous faisons.
Mais avant de faire ça -- et c’est une autre de mes manies --
Je voudrais parler un peu de qui sont les pauvres.
Parce que nous parlons souvent d’eux comme ces
immenses masses qui aspirent à la liberté,
alors qu’en fait, c’est une histoire stupéfiante.
Au niveau macro, 4 milliards d’humains sur Terre gagnent moins de 4 dollars par jour.
Voilà de qui nous parlons lorsque nous pensons aux pauvres.
If vous agrégez tout ça, c’est la 3ème plus grande économie du monde,
et pourtant la plupart de ces gens sont invisibles.
Là où nous travaillions généralement, les gens gagnent entre
un et trois dollars par jour.
Qui sont ces gens ?
Ce sont des fermiers et des ouvriers.
Ils travaillent dans des bureaux du gouvernement. Ils sont chauffeurs.
Ils sont employés de maison.
Ils paient généralement pour des biens et services essentiels tels que l’eau,
les soins, le logement, et ils paient 30 à 40 fois
ce que leurs homologues de la classe moyenne paient --
certainement là où nous travaillons à Karachi et Nairobi.
Les pauvres aussi veulent prendre, et prennent, des décisions intelligentes,
si vous leur en donnez l’opportunité.
Donc, deux exemples.
L’un est l’Inde, où il y a 240 millions d’agriculteurs,
dont la plupart gagnent moins de 2 dollars par jour.
Quand nous travaillons à Aurangabad, la terre est incroyablement desséchée.
Vous voyez des gens qui gagnet entre 60 centimes et 1 dollar.
L’homme en rose est un entrepreneur social nommé Ami Tabar.
Ce qu’il a fait c’est voir ce qui se faisait en Israël, à plus grande échelle,
et comprendre comment fonctionnait un système d’irrigation goutte-à-goutte,
qui est un moyen d’apporter de l’eau directement là où la plante en a besoin.
Mais auparavant cela avait été fait seulement pour des grandes exploitations,
donc Ami Tabar a pris ce système et l’a transformé en modules adaptés à 500 mètres carrés.
Quelques principes --
Construire à petite échelle.
Concevoir pour une extension à l’infini et un coût abordable pour les pauvres.
Cette famille, Sarita et son mari, a acheté un module à 15 dollars
quand ils vivaient dans -- littéralement, 3 murs en appentis
avec un toit en tôle ondulée.
Après une récolte, ils avaient suffisamment augmentés leurs revenus
pour acheter un second système pour équiper complètement leurs 1000 mètres carrés de terrain.
Deux ans plus tard, je les ai rencontrés.
Ils gagnent maintenant 4 dollars par jour, ce qui est plutôt dans la classe moyenne pour l’Inde,
et ils m’ont montré les fondations en béton qui venaient de couler
pour construire leur maison.
Et je vous jure, je pouvais voir le futur dans les yeux de cette femme.
Quelque chose en quoi je crois profondément.
On ne peut pas aujourd’hui parler de pauvreté sans parler de moustiquaires contre le paludisme,
et je dis à nouveau toute mon admiration à Jeffrey Sachs de Harvard
pour avoir mis sur la scène mondiale
cette idée tirée de son engagement -- pour 5 dollars vous pouvez sauver une vie.
Le paludisme est une maladie qui tue de 1 à 3 millions de personnes par an.
On compte 300 à 500 millions de cas.
On estime que l’Afrique perd
environ 13 milliards de dollars par an à cause de cette maladie.
5 dollars peuvent sauver une vie.
Nous pouvons envoyer des gens sur la Lune, nous pouvons voir s’il y a de la vie sur Mars --
pourquoi ne pouvons-nous pas avoir des moustiquaires à 5 dollars pour 500 millions de personnes ?
La question, cependant, n’est pas “Pourquoi ne pouvons-nous pas ? ”,
la question est comment pouvons nous aider les Africains à le faire pour eux-mêmes ?
Beaucoup d’obstacles.
Un : la production est trop faible. Deux : le prix est trop élevé.
Trois : la route dans -- heu, près de là où notre usine est située.
La logistique est un cauchemar, mais ce n’est pas impossible.
Nous avons commencé par faire un prêt de 350 000 dollars
au plus grand fabricant traditionnel de moustiquaires en Afrique
pour qu’ils puissent transférer une technologie provenant du Japon
et fabriquer ces moustiquaires longue-durée qui durent 5 ans.
Voici juste quelques images de l’usine.
Aujourd’hui, trois ans plus tard, l’entreprise a embauché
1000 femmes supplémentaires.
Cela contribue à hauteur de 600 000 dollars en salaires à l’économie tanzanienne.
C’est la plus grande entreprise de Tanzanie.
La capacité de production atteint 1,5 millions de moustiquaires par an à l’heure actuelle,
elle sera de 3 millions par an à la fin de l’année.
Nous espérons avoir une capacité de 7 millions à la fin de l’année prochaine.
Donc l’aspect productif du projet fonctionne.
L’aspect logistique, par contre,
nous dans le monde entier, avons beaucoup à faire.
Aujourd’hui, 95 % des moustiquaires sont achetées par l’O.N.U,
et ensuite distribuées en gros à travers l’Afrique.
Nous cherchons à construire
sur l’un des plus précieuses ressources africaines -- les Africains.
Ses femmes.
Et je veux vous présenter Jacqueline,
mon homonyme, 21 ans.
Si elle était née ailleurs qu’en Tanzanie,
croyez-moi, elle pourrait être à Wall Street.
Elle gère 2 lignes de production, et a déjà mis suffisamment de côté
pour verser un acompte pour sa maison.
Elle gagne environ 2 dollars par jour, met sur pied un fond éducatif,
et m’a dit qu’elle ne se marierait ni n’aurait d’enfants
avant que ces choses ne soient mises en place.
Et donc, quand je lui ai parlé de notre idée --
que peut-être nous pourrions adopter le modèle Tupperware des Etats-Unis,
et trouver un moyen pour que les femmes elles-mêmes aillent
vendre ces moustiquaires aux autres --
elle a fait le calcul rapidement pour voir combien elle pourrait gagner
et a adhéré au projet.
Nous avons appris de l’expérience d’IDEO, une de nos entreprises favorites,
et rapidement nous avons expérimenté le système,
et emmené Jacqueline dans la zone où elle habite.
Elle a amené 10 des femmes qu’elle fréquente
les réunissant pour savoir si elle pouvait vendre ces moustiquaires, à 5 dollars pièce,
en dépit du fait que les gens disaient que personne n’en n’achèterait,
et nous avons appris beaucoup sur la façon dont vendre des choses.
Non pas en arrivant avec notre idée de la question,
parce qu’elle n’abordait la question du paludisme qu’à la toute fin en fait.
D’abord, elle parlait du confort, du statut, de la beauté.
Ces moustiquaires, disait-elle, vous les mettez par terre, les insectes quittent la maison.
Les enfants passent une bonne nuit,
la maison a l’air belle, vous les pendez aux fenêtres.
Et nous avons commencé à faire des rideaux,
et non seulement c’est joli, mais les gens peuvent voir le statut que cela apporte --
que vous prenez soin de vos enfants.
Seulement alors elle parlait de sauver la vie des enfants.
De nombreuses leçons doivent être apprises en termes de marketing de vente
de biens et services à destination des pauvres.
Et je veux juste finir en disant qu’il y a une énorme opportunité
de faire de la pauvreté une histoire ancienne.
Pour bien le faire, nous devons construire des modèles d’entreprise qui font sens,
de taille flexible et qui marchent avec les Africains, les Indiens,
les gens dans le monde en développement
ou qui tombent dans cette catégorie, pour qu’ils le fassent eux-mêmes.
Parce qu’au bout du compte, c’est une question d’engagement.
Il s’agit de comprendre que les gens ne veulent vraiment de la charité,
ils veulent prendre leurs propres décisions,
ils veulent résoudre leurs propres problèmes,
et en nous engageant avec eux,
non seulement nous créons bien plus de dignité pour eux,
mais aussi pour nous.
Et je vous encourage vivement la prochaine fois à penser
à comment nous nous impliquons avec cette idée et cette opportunité
que nous avons tous -- faire de la pauvreté une histoire ancienne --
en faisant réellement partie du processus
et en se détachant de ce monde séparé entre nous et eux,
et en réalisant qu’il s’agit de nous tous,
et le genre de monde que, tous ensemble, nous voulons partager et dans lequel nous voulons vivre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)